we got americans fake caring about cuba
what y'all think about that what y'all
faith caring about today yeah what do
you what do you think about that the
fake caring about cuba
i just heard i thought it was
interesting they're protesting in cuba
well yeah that's where i'm like that's
interesting with protesting here
yeah okay oh protesting something who
gives a [ __ ] yeah that's a swap meet
that's just swapping a bunch of cubans
getting together bro that's nothing
yeah but we got to support it those are
people they took care of us when we're
down in miami so
yeah yeah yeah for sure but what i'm
curious about is why this is becoming
like a national news story
right like the the american press has
given this a lot of juice
that's a good point because i will say
when i said the first time in 25 years i
was like that's
kind of a long time yeah it's just nine
years is kind of like it's not
so it's not i thought it was like
[ __ ] 75 80 like i thought since
castro's in power and then
you're not really gonna [ __ ] protest
90 was like elian doug
yeah they were protesting in the 90s i
don't know why but that's 25 years ago
son i got the feeling i got the feeling
and just because i scroll read it i got
this feeling i think we got the same
feeling okay
this is america trying to shore up
the western hemisphere color revolution
this what color revolution you just they
go in they're just like all right swap
out the guards
america's like all right the jig is up
oh color revolution
okay i thought there was more like a
racial undertone no no no okay
uh but america's gonna go in and they're
gonna like pluck out the
the dictator put in their guy yes and
then
i wonder if haiti's got something to do
with this as well
because china's been trying to make
their way into the west right they've
been trying to make their way into the
caribbean they've
had like five different countries there
sign on to like the uh
the belt with a belt and road initiative
or something like that
yeah um basically what that is i'm sure
they received some sort of economic
resources but the idea is they could
like
facilitate certain chinese ideas that
they want i think america is basically
going
all right one thing that i read it could
be absolute [ __ ] it's like
we're pulling out of the middle east
because it's too expensive i think we
just left afghanistan didn't even tell
them [ __ ] irish good bach
you didn't have your country you woke up
the next day it's yours yeah yeah i mean
left a note maybe
maybe just left you to base man right
but what's crazy is that people were
complaining that oh biden's gonna bring
us back into war and now he's pulling
out and now people are
knocking him for pulling out so quick
he's like can't do anything right
you want us to be there or not even the
afghan president was like they didn't
say goodbye [ __ ] what you want
salutations [ __ ] friends now
we're friends
enjoy your heroin fields so so what
people were saying is that china is
trying to get into the caribbean
trying to get their influence into south
america central america of course makes
sense i'm sure that's what we would do
out there in asia
and maybe we realized okay it's going to
be hard to compete on a global scale
right with china so we got to shore up
our part of the world
so maybe one way looking at it is like
listen we got north america south
america central america
i guess and europe and then they
potentially got the rest
the tricky thing is the rest could be
the middle east
you know and i don't think so because we
just have so many bases out there so
much influence and so much protection
for certain countries that absolutely
need it but
we got to figure out who divides that
important part if they want to take asia
all right i don't think they get india
though i think the u.s is going to try
to prop up india
and that's a like all jokes aside that's
a billion people just raw numbers yeah
1.4 billion or whatever out of eight
gold
i hope india is not the proxy war to be
honest with you like i hope we don't
fight our war
with china through india that could
happen
but that's dangerous because india's got
nukes bro like
proxy wars got to happen between people
that don't have real weapons right
or crazy crazy weapons so you still get
casualties but you're not having like
global economic destruction
yeah but once a new goes off yeah i
thought i thought it would be over
africa
i thought we were going to try to get
some of that back because china has
almost all of africa
they just went all in on africa very
smart also
that's real smart yeah hopefully we took
out the resources and all the athletes
and everything and like
yeah we got a couple of ufc fighters out
of that yeah
did we get them out safe we got them all
yeah maybe that's
maybe that's how the us is going to take
back africa
hey we're going to prop up this western
ass event ufc
a lot of spectacle and y'all are going
to be the best guys
can i be honest with you we're going to
win that culture team usa
lost to nigeria basketball yeah if i'm
china son
i am propping up the most
modernized african nations that are
invested culturally in certain sports
that are popular in the west basketball
being one of them and i'm just
dumping bread in i'm dumping bread
because it looks horrible for america
when we lose
yeah in our sports we lose a soccer
nobody really give a [ __ ]
but if we start losing in basketball
baseball how the [ __ ] did you lose
to j cole's league
j cole really the legend j cole was
dropping buckets in the league we can't
beat these [ __ ]
come on come on bro this is this is a
disaster
real pro how he lives in nigeria dog
come on
it's not like it's not the actual
all-stars right on we kevin durant's on
that team
dave lillard on that team they lost in
nigeria yeah
nigeria hit like 26 threes or something
like that i don't care how you let him
hit 26 threes
that's a good ass point son how are you
you made a good ass point right
that's a good ass point and i can't even
blame the finals how'd they score more
points than our team scored points yeah
[ __ ] up that they would do that's a
good ass point
[Laughter]
yeah [ __ ] oh yeah you want to
talk about that soccer show oh no back
to what we were talking about the cuba
thing
so i think obviously anytime there's
like a freedom fight in cuba
yeah right same way what happens with
like um in venezuela it's like we almost
like use these countries
as reasons for why america shouldn't
and i'm gonna put this in quotes like
devolve into socialism some people might
assume that's
evolution but it doesn't matter but like
they just stand there so as long as
venezuela looks shitty we get to go
see what socialism yeah see with
universal healthcare
see yeah i mean don't look over there in
europe but like see what happens you
know
and and cuba as well like as long as
people are suffering in cuba
americans like conservative americans
they don't love that they're suffering
but they love that they get to when does
communism ever work
exactly yeah exactly it's that same
thing and every i mean america's done it
over and over
like the most famous one was the uh
modern art
during the cold war oh you remember
talking about this yeah yeah yeah
like i don't know if we talk about it
here but like basically cia was dumping
money into like modern art like jackson
pollock guys like like these like
post-modernist like expressionist guys
like something real free form
to try to like push like create a
culture war against like the russians
yeah they're like russian art is like so
structured and brutalist but look at us
bro we're free you can do anything like
art is whatever you want it to be and
that is such an intoxicating idea
yeah freedom is so intoxicating look at
our art look at our musical our movies
everything is just
free but it's kind of wild they like
completely discredit those artists like
right like you thought that they were
like super talented like once in a while
i have a gift from god
nah i never understood that the cia boss
was just like yeah that [ __ ] weirdo
who's just nutting all over the campus
yeah isn't that crazy dictate what we
like it is crazy and i bet they're even
more effective now with the internet
like back in the day you had to convince
[ __ ] with magazines and they
had to like sit there and read
like they're affecting it because they
own the social media
ah like you promote the [ __ ] that's pop
apparently they're like uh
i've read this i'm not positive how
accurate is but like they're blocking
tick tock users
that have like black lives matter in
their bio or like they're suppressing
their views and stuff
oh wow like take a look we know for the
fact that they could turn the lever on
academics told us that [ __ ] yeah so they
can just promote whatever the [ __ ] they
want same thing happen
we're witnessing we're falling back into
it
like first thing happened with music now
the music companies have complete
control
who the artists are going to be
successful who are like that's back to
them
and we're probably gonna witness a
similar thing happen with social media
companies as well so you think they're
gonna go
do similar to what they did with russia
where like something
incredibly american and free becomes
like really popular in the art world
you never know maybe i mean like i don't
know if jackson pollock and them were
seen as like uh universally american
but they did seem uh uh like the
complete
opposite of what russian art was at the
time yes
right like uh there was a and i don't
know maybe that they do that
maybe they do it here maybe they
showcase i don't know that's a great
question
and you i want the u.s to win this war
because you can the american government
is not perfect
by any stretch but if you think the
chinese government is better to live
under
you're a [ __ ] idiot yeah and we need
to win this war and our only real chance
is culture war
yo you know what we got to do we gotta
do what the jews do but like the
opposite
you know how like if you're jewish you
go to israel they'll just pay for your
trip right because they're like yo being
jewish is so dope you don't want to be
jewish
[ __ ] but we'll pay for your trip to go
to china yeah then after you go there
you'll come out i will fight for this
country
every every red blood cell in my body
not when you come back if you come back
right we got to start promoting travel
get everybody a passport see how
[ __ ] is out there
real talk america's not traveling they
don't know how shitty the world is
you think america does that with korean
pop bands what do you mean
they're like yo let's throw a bunch of
money at bts let's blow them up crazy
because like if we have these korean
guys popping that's going to piss china
off
because it's not a korean or not a
chinese group we're going to make like
their enemies pop off
uh that's an interesting take i don't
know if anything i would think that they
would promote americanness
right like but it does show that
we're accepting you go over there if you
adopt western light we'll still
let you in here you could be the biggest
band in the world it doesn't matter if
you're asian
yeah anybody in asia just come do our
stuff are you talking about like
through a reward structure are you like
yeah i see what you're saying
yes yes yes let's put on all of china's
enemies
as long as they conform to american
standards and entertainment
yes yeah rock with us we'll make you
superstars over here and just like piss
off
are there any like chinese superstars
like like as far as like
in china that are have bled over i don't
think
yeah i don't know if china will allow it
china it was tough to get yamang over
anytime there's a good chinese baseball
player at
any other chinese i think it's tough to
get them all it's like it's tough to get
people from china
because the chinese government's like
nah that's nice baseball like that i was
always thought it was like
i remember yao it was tough to get yao
to america yeah the chinese government
was not letting him over
because the government decides whether
or not you get to come play and so
it's really tough to get those guys over
so you're not going to see chinese
superstars in america because china
won't let that [ __ ] happen that's their
guy
so what we can do to your point is make
everybody else
famous in america and then get all of
their people like if you're korean
you're looking at bts like the biggest
band in the world i love these guys and
if they're super western and super like
into freedom and expression and all that
that's the culture i want to be a part
of that's the cool culture and low key
there's not as much of a reason for them
to come over
because you can get breaded out there oh
yeah like they have the population
yeah the biggest artists in uh trinidad
and
tobago like you need to break out
somewhere yeah yeah like
you know like the biggest the biggest i
don't know dancehall artists in trinidad
and tobago
got a day job yeah if he hasn't broken
out into at least the other parts of the
caribbean
europe america you need the population
density at
a bare minimum right so yeah man it's
tricky
you know what i'm reading this cuba
stuff you know what i thought was when i
thought maybe the us
is doing some some [ __ ] is when biden
started talking about it
then i was like oh maybe this is like a
part of it they're trying to get
castro out of there and it couldn't have
started he's out you're talking about
like his family
yeah oh yeah like the the communist
regime out of there yeah and i was
wondering if it started eight years ago
when obama was like hey let's start
letting people back into cuba that's the
beginning of it oh so
start letting the west over there we did
a reverse yeah like
interesting interesting interesting
interesting instead of saying [ __ ] you
communism you're not allowed to do
business with us that clearly didn't
work
casper was still in power his family was
still in power all right so let's just
open it up
let's just get them exposed to the west
again let's start doing this thing and
then we'll just get them the [ __ ] out of
there
my understanding is you couldn't do [ __ ]
nothing happened with trump no no no
this is biden
i mean obama to biden there was a gap in
between four years
the people are saying that's really
interesting because people are saying
that the like the riots
were about um like economic frustration
right like obviously because of covid
they're spiking again not enough
vaccines not have access to the hospital
so they're saying it was a it was
frustration due to like lives being lost
right and their economy i think is down
10 this is already a depressed economy
i'm sure that has to do with tourism and
like a lack of tourism yeah but uh they
have a curfew at like nine o'clock
and [ __ ] like that and they said a lot
of protesters went back at nine
but but still i like that idea like
maybe this is the way that you
infiltrate you get some spies in there
you get and and low-key it's kind of
like payback for what castro did to us
remember when we were like all right
we'll let you guys send some people back
home and he sent
all like the murderers and rapists and
[ __ ] like that yeah oh yeah
that was his yeah i think he put them
all in jail
and then when we gave him a plane to
send people back home yeah
he sent the people he didn't want the
island yeah yeah [ __ ] that's a
ballsy move son
yeah yeah no i like akash take because
it's like when you open
open it up and then americans start
going over there and now cubans are
seeing
all the [ __ ] they're missing out on it's
like oh wow americans are here
where they're free they do whatever the
hell they want
they're nice they got money they get to
do whatever like they see in a lifestyle
that they
aren't living and so now they're more
likely to speak out against that
government that is a great point
because our greatest tool is our culture
yeah and if we can't share a culture
it's like why does china limit so many
movies why is china limited so many tv
shows why does it limit all of our
are like not all but a lot of our
musicians and [ __ ] because that
stranglehold that we'll have over your
people is through our culture russia did
the same thing
they banned all american movies all
through the cold war there's actually a
bollywood
like surge in russia yeah that makes
sense because they were like yeah
any americans so they're like all right
you can have indian movies there's like
all these like random russian like 40
year olds are like yeah we [ __ ] love
yeah it's weird yeah really yeah it's it
is crazy how big it is like in africa
they love bali with them at least they
live bollywood russia i heard they live
bollywood in certain parts
and i didn't know it was necessarily
because of communism but yeah it is it
it's a thing i noticed
i see so many people will be like i love
bollywood hollywood is like your wedding
song
it's just a big ass party colors dancing
yeah
it's all about joy hero's journey heroes
journey every single one
hero's journey and also i thought about
like why are all bollywood movies always
so like
rich people and escape whatever yeah and
for it is
if you're a poor person yeah i don't
want to see reality
[ __ ] reality it sucks i want to escape
yeah exactly exactly so that makes sense
you had mentioned
um that there might be some connection
with the cuba and haiti [ __ ]
like i'm curious like if this is us
shoring up the west like what you say
color war right
mm-hmm is yeah not it's basically going
like all right
who is that president loyal to the
haitian president does he have any
loyalty to anybody else but us oh you do
adios yeah i don't know that [ __ ] was
wild though i'm kind of cynical with
that like
did you did y'all hear how it happened
though like his own security
yeah they got hired and then like no so
yeah big group goes over there and then
they start saying dea dea so
his security just lets them in because
they're thinking it's [ __ ] american
government yeah
and then they just took a took him and
his wife out i mean
actually the wife i think is still
incredible let's be honest that's just
wild though
like you need to get a team of those to
get a team of those people down there
into the country with certain weapons
with certain
outfits it's not like you're just to get
that [ __ ] at the [ __ ] halloween store
right yeah
have certain connections who is it's
going to take somebody with serious
money and influence
even to get that close yeah right like
i'm not saying it's the american
government that's exercising it maybe
it's a foreign government maybe it's
[ __ ] china who knows
but it's gonna take somebody like at the
higher levels of power and influence to
orchestrate something like that
also somebody that could gain a ton like
if you're just some like russian
billionaire like what are you getting
from killing because he said something
mean to you no that's not how the game
works like at that point you could say
whatever you want we got billions of
dollars
at stake here yeah so the fact that they
were american
could mean it's america or if i was
gonna hire somebody
if i'm china or if i'm another country
and i wanted to
make sure we murked a president that
wasn't doing the things that we wanted
them to do
i wouldn't make sure that the passports
led back to china yeah
do you remember when the russians took
out that um
russian oligarch in london he drank some
tea i think his name was berezovsky or
something like that
and he he drank some tea and there was
polonium in it or something like that
you can trace radioactive material like
physically trace it
back to wherever it is and they traced
it back to the hospital that those
russian guys
that killed him were in russia yeah
jesus so you know they took them out
yeah right so they're like oh we're not
making that mistake again
why don't you hire people from the
country
that looks like it would benefit from
this you hire some americans
that have haitian descent to go handle
business now looks like america got
blood on their hands right
yeah this [ __ ] is straight out of bond
movie yeah yeah i guess you just have to
see what the outcome is like if the
outcome is
super beneficial to america then it's
like yeah cia
whoever whoever benefits from this yeah
did it whoever actually benefits not who
optically could benefit but right
whoever actually has benefit from it
yeah like the next go go i don't know
i'm just cynical where like i don't know
if there's been any
like revolution in the last like 50
years that's not
orchestrated by some government yeah i
mean like when people are like oh yeah
like these people in iran are mad it's
like
are they they're not he also had a lot
of enemies though like he didn't like
the
the rich class because there's like a
few families that just own everything in
haiti yeah so he wasn't [ __ ] with
them and so
it could be one of these rich people hey
let's get them the [ __ ] out of here and
not
make it look like it was one of us well
we know about the doctor who was
arrested now right
so in haiti one of the suspects is a
doctor that flew on a private jet
i think a few days before who the idea
the plan was that these guys were gonna
actually go
into the presidential palace take him to
um
i think take him take him somewhere a
government building and
stage a coup and so he's in custody so
oh wow
on that so they're saying he wasn't
supposed to be
killed but then when he described how
the president was killed i was like yeah
he was
that yeah he was this was
this was out of a movie the description
yeah but that's the other thing that
the conspiracy theorists will say right
is that they'll say that like the cia
the fbi the nsa like these institutions
don't just work for the government they
work for the rich people that benefit
the most from the government
so if you have a bunch of rich families
who surely have like
some ties to america or other places
that can use their influence and the
influence of their
you know security apparatus yeah to
you know push things in their direction
this might be one of those things they
got to push yeah but this is a big
conversation like you take out a head of
state i don't care if it's
a small country anyone that's a big
[ __ ] deal being like
there's something going on here there's
something going on here
yeah like i know a lot of money got sent
over there to haiti right
right that didn't really get to the
haitian people remember when there was
that hurricane
like who knows if homeboy was about to
blow the top off of that um
i mean there was even some criticism of
how like the uh
the clinton foundation handled that
wasn't that yeah yeah yep
yeah remember like they were like
kidnapping or not kidding they like
adopted all those haitian kids
remember the clintons yeah that that's
that's tricky right
what do you mean there was like uh like
they were trying to pin that
on uh the clintons right that these kids
were being like stolen but they were
also being like adopted
and like some of the parents were like
no they weren't like there was there was
not clear cut obviously it's not clear
and so it could
possibly be that but i don't think
there's enough money in that
i know it sounds [ __ ] up but like 14
kids being adopted or whatever it is
it sounds [ __ ] up but like i don't
think that's what moves the world
yeah i think billions of dollars moves
the world and when
billions was were raised or maybe tens
of millions were raised to the clinton
foundation and it just never got there
right yeah and that president is like oh
now we know where it went
oh this is cute yeah maybe some people
need to know about where it went
you